we'll take five suggestions one from
each quarter and then a wild card I will
come to this quadrant first what would
you like a rap about dirty socks thank
you very much
straight up gosh I'm having flashbacks
to my mother this segment here okay
someone down here said parasail and then
annoyingly someone over there was just
like yeah the Japanese feudal system and
you said it so loud that means I
couldn't do that thing where I kind of
ignore it because it was quite difficult
dirty socks the Japanese feudal system
quadrant here what we going with surfing
last week someone suggested search
surfboard so I feel that's too close to
that I'm not going to take that
suggestion sorry though
very disappointing surfers there oh man
that is so the opposite of this let's
get a new suggestion jump rope okay jump
rope jump rope dirty socks Japanese
feudal system this side David Beckham
yeah do you have a particular own thing
about David Beckham the interest in I've
met David quite a few times
we're on first-name terms I mean by that
I mean I call him David he calls me who
but date David Beckham what specific
thing about David Beckham it's frosted
tips I love that you said football you
were trying out you were like I don't
know anything by Ambar relate and call
it what the British call it football
everyone else is like it's soccer you
fool don't bow down to him no bowing
down this isn't the Japanese feudal
system I think that's a good reference
David Beckham's frosted tips jump rope
the Japanese feudal system smelly or
dirty socks one final one this is gonna
be the best one right I mean it's not
Japanese feudal systems clearly the best
one but we'll pretend that this one is
is the the peace resistant what's it
going to be there were two at the same
time someone said Apollo watt Apollo 9 2
before Apollo a foot before Apollo 13
Apollo 9 did that actually did that land
on the moon you don't think so
I hope you do not work for NASA I think
it's still floating around out there
it didn't so Wow and it was its gesture
from down here as well with that was so
that was you as well so you you
suggested boy bands in the 90s and then
knew that Apollo 9 did not land on the
moon
you know things I like that a half of
Tyrion Lannister in Game of Thrones also
drinking that's there for one I like you
you're you're wonderful you also remind
me of Bjork is that okay to say yeah
yeah hey you're too bloody hottie so boy
bands of the 90s Apollo 9 jump broke
dirty socks the Japanese feudal system
and David Beckham's frosted tips that
was roughly all of them right cool
this then lovely people at the most of
each comedy magic club to close out the
show a little treat for your called a
freestyle rap that's a rap made up on
the spot based entirely on those
suggestions it's not prepared he's not
rehearsed it will never be performed
again only about all those things let's
roll that track and see what we come up
with I'm excited and you can
[Music]
[Music]
the great gentle gravity okay so you
know what swing right with a golf club
the ball riding with this pair of dirty
socks a keeper button is my sneakers
rippled out yet holes in them so it's
easy right a cup of tea with himself as
dr. Kennedy feeder tears and any other
underwear my leggings to hop on the web
for job stress B strings dirty socks are
always worry finding these things under
teenage boys bed because they go through
at such a rate now we tell what they do
in Jack ulation in the socks bed is not
a nice thing in the mm in the
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Styles capacity of tips in the feudal
system they bow down to their boss they
can miss a cuckoo that is too aside if
the fountain the Lord has been
assassinated guide they would wander
around chanting show him in the
afterlife feudal system as thrown in
that's a fact I learned it from a lupus
on film spear where Robert De Niro I
love him and other things yet it was
home so unpleasant if you are Japanese
put your work into the peasant what do
you do
rise up mutiny and say we need more
things that sushi and green tea we want
to find things that you've got in the
palace yeah we can finish there cheers
no malice there you go
you